being in the icu in a kind of
slowly starting to think sinking of what
happened to me because
like right off the stroke i couldn't
walk i was in a wheelchair it could
i mean i'm not able to walk with it with
a cage shorter distances
now and now you walk with a cane shorter
so i really had a rehab to learn how to
walk
i still wear leg brace because the um
the muscles around my
my my left ankle aren't can't support me
so
if i were wearing the brace would just
when i would go down
and my left arm is to my left hand and
arm hand doesn't work
so i'm doing therapies for that and
that's slow but it's a little bit better
than it was like before there used to be
absolutely nothing on my arm but now
i've got a little shoulder movement
all right so i'm making slow progress
but anyway so as it was sort of
hitting me what the hell was going on i
literally said to myself
wait a second you became a successful
actor you beat hollywood
the stroke's nothing like recovering
from a stroke like i can do this
what a way see to put things in
perspective like that i mean
was it like that from the get-go you
wait take me back to the point where you
wake up
in the emergency room or in the hospital
and your wife's there is she with the
kids and like
what is what's going through your mind
and what's going through her mind and
what so i
when i when the stroke first hit me i
was in bathroom in the temp airport and
i collapsed my left
leg my left leg went out front of me i
collapsed got up collapsed again
i guess someone got me out into the
waiting area where there were
some paramedics came and attended to me
and there'd
a bunch of people shouting at me and um
you know they're doing the
the stroke checklist of show us your
teeth tell us your name what year is it
who's the president and i literally i
was still with enough to think
i mean my normally joke could have been
haven't i suffered enough
but i i was with enough to think wait a
second you're in florida these are first
responders
these are probably trump people don't
crack wise you need these guys on your
side
don't be an right now right
right so i was thinking that clearly
enough to do that
and then i remember being in this
putting out a gurney and i'm
in the back of the ambulance my legs are
kind of up like this you know
and um i remember looking at the um the
texture of my jeans
just i just noticed the weave of the
fabric and it kind of hit me like
this is not good you got you got a wife
because you gotta get
this is not good
you